the 2020 election has shown just how
profoundly education politics have
shifted for decades Republicans used
education to demonstrate compassion and
signal the sincerity of their commitment
to equal opportunity Democrats used
education to show that they were more
interested in offering a hand up than in
handouts today neither side is all that
concerned about us waging the middle or
signaling pragmatism education is now
playing an amped-up role in primary
campaigns in 2016 Donald Trump hammered
Jeb Bush with the Common Core in 2020
Trump is energetically embraced school
vouchers and use them to draw a sharp
contrast with Democrats in the
Democratic primary candidates have raced
to one-up each other on free college
loan forgiveness and teacher pay whether
Trump or a Democrat claims the White
House in 2020 it's clear that the winner
will be less inclined to compromise and
more likely to stick with the more
partisan playbook welcome to education
to new normal do you think education
will be a big issue in the 2020 election
let us know in our poll also let us know
what other topics you'd like our
scholars to cover in 60 seconds and be
sure to LIKE and subscribe for more
research and videos from AEI